ce matin c'est stanislas guérini bonjour
et merci beaucoup d'être avec le député
farid déléguée générale de la république
en marche on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour fabrice veysseyre dans
bonjour au riad du groupe
bonjour c'est tous les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france on
commence bien sûr cette année c est fini
par cette décision hier du conseil
constitutionnel qui est tombée en fin
d'après midi et qui a censuré une grande
partie de la proposition de loi sécurité
globale dont un article sur les drones
et dont l'article 24 qui ne
s'appellerait comme ça mais on va dire
que c'est l'article 24 qui crée un délit
de provocation à l'identification des
forces de l'ordre est ce que c'est un
désaveu pour le gouvernement et pour
gérald darmanin au d'abord moi je
respecte toujours quand le conseil qu'on
sait suède prend des décisions je crois
que c'est plutôt sain dans notre
démocratie de se tenir à ces lignes
raisonnable maintenant ça veut dire
qu'il faudra reprendre notre bâton de
pèlerin sur des sujets où légitimement
on veut protéger les policiers
vous savez cette femme article 24 qui a
fait couler tant d'encre
il avait cheminé il avait été réécrit
par le sénat et le gouvernement avaient
sagement décidé de conserver ou c'était
plutôt dans le cas d'une commission
mixte paritaire
cette écriture là qui était consensuelle
entre les deux chambres et pourquoi elle
était consensuel parce que l'objectif de
fond c'est à dire protéger ce qui nous
protège étaient partagés est-ce que cet
objectif et reste légitime aujourd'hui
la réponse est oui
et malheureusement l'actualité la plus
récente la plus tragique montre à quel
point on a besoin de protéger des
policiers donc ça veut dire qu'on s'est
laissé aller
sur vous n'abandonnez pas ce texte oui
moi je crois que ce sera nécessaire on
parle de l'article 24 mais aussi
d'autres dispositions qui sont utiles ce
texte de loi pour la sécurité globale
c'est un texte qui avait qui comporte de
nombreuses avancées beaucoup sont
d'ailleurs confortées par le conseil
constitutionnel
et puis pour celle qui est effectivement
aujourd'hui ont été remises en cause
eh bien il faudra réécrire il faudra
retravailler
parce que les objectifs de fond eux ils
restent bien légitime quand il de quelle
manière du coup ça va être qu'il est en
ce moment un bout de la sécurité se sont
évidemment encore beaucoup de réflexion
beaucoup d'avancé qu'il faudra apporter
pour apporter des moyens pour réfléchir
aux modifications législatives pour
mieux protéger nos concitoyens je crois
que cette attente là elle est partagée
au delà même des clivages politiques
traditionnels et donc peut-être qu'à
l'issue du beauvau il y aura nécessité
de porter quelques modifications
législatives
si à ce moment là on peut revenir de
façon évidemment retravailler sur les
dispositions qui ont été retoqués par le
conseil constitutionnel
alors ça serait une bonne chose soit
dans la loi de sécurité intérieure qui
est prévue à l'issue de charvaux je
pense que ça peut être effectivement un
véhicule législatif qui peut être tout à
fait adapté donc pas avant non je ne
pense pas je pense qu'il faut pas
forcément se précipite et voilà le
conseil qu'on sait c'est là dit revoyez
votre copie au sénat et à l'assemblée
bon ben il faut le faire et je pense
qu'il faut peut-être profiter de ce
véhicule législatif la réf
vous avez une pression qui est assez
forte le côté des militaires plusieurs
tribunes dans les médias les policiers
qui manifestent sous les fenêtres de
l'assemblée nationale vous évoquez le
bourreau de sécurité vous aviez vu venir
cette cette situation c'est cette
pression des forces de l'ordre sur le
sol couverts vous savez vous vous
évoquez des choses qui a à mon sens ne
sont pas de même nature
cette tribune qui n'en est pas une qui
est plus un sorte de pétition en ligne
qui était anonyme je n'avais pas mais
vraiment pas du tout sur le même plan
que
que vous soyez particulière comme par
celle des policiers
il faut prendre en compte le contexte
évidemment voyez dans le débat public on
a parfois la mémoire un peu courte
à quelques jours à peine nous étions en
train de pleurer la mémoire de forces de
l'ordre policiers qui ont été
odieusement assassiné ça c'est le
contexte qu'il faut avoir en tête et ça
nous ne pouvons pas accepter cela dans
un pays de droit et donc oui cette
pression là c'était pas celle des
policiers
cette pression là c'est la pression de
notre société qui ne peut pas accepter
cette situation où on tue ce qui nous
protège pas ce qu'ils font leur métier
au quotidien parce qu'ils vont lutter
contre la drogue qui gangrènent gangrène
nos enfants et nos quartiers donc ça
c'est une pression légitime je dirais
après effectivement il y a par dessus ça
une storck de récupération politique
une sorte d'ambiance que veut installer
l'extrême droite notamment
et puis des pressions sur la justice est
bien celle là je crois qu'elles ne sont
pas acceptables parce que la police et
la justice
eh bien elles doivent travailler
ensemble ce sont des maillons essentiels
et on le sait et tous ceux qui
travaillent sur ces sujets de sécurité
savent qu'ils doivent travailler
ensemble mais tous ceux qui veulent
opposer et sauf que la justice et la
police commettent des erreurs lourdes et
les erreurs lourdes
je crois pour notre démocratie sans les
opposer vous même vous reconnaissez au
sein du gouvernement et de la majorité
qu'il faut renforcer la réponse pénale
vous avez bien posé plusieurs mesures ça
veut dire que vous aussi vous êtes quand
même conscient qu'à peut-être certain
laxisme de la justice aujourd'hui sur
ces questions ne sont pas les termes que
j'utiliserai je crois que la justice est
là pendant longtemps manqué de moyens et
le disait elle-même est d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui mannequin
l'instance pénale et d'effectivité des
peines prononcées là les deux sujets
mais d'abord la question des moyens pour
que la justice soit plus efficace il
faut qu'elle ait les moyens pour pouvoir
travailler et le garde des sceaux ennemi
intérieur
il travaille de façon absolument
harmonieuse sur ces questions-là eux ne
travaillent pas en nous posant
l'institution judiciaire et
l'institution policière
donc nous devons continuer à avancer
adapter notre arsenal législatif est
souvent d'ailleurs dans un sens que vous
évoquez qui est celui de l'effectivité
des peines
je crois que ce qui décrédibilise
l'institution judiciaire
parfois c'est le manque d'effectivité
des peines est patent faire la course à
l'échalote de la mesure la plus
symbolique
jusqu'à quel âge avait sera ton le seuil
pénal etc nous avons un arsenal mais je
sais qu'il est régressif talent et ça se
gagne nous conseille moi par exemple
est-ce que le bracelet électronique par
exemple c'est une peine effective pour
vous gâche je pense que c'est une peine
nécessaire qui est souvent parfois
justement une alternative à des peines
non effectuées
je pense aussi à tous ces délits du
quotidien vous savez nous parlions à
l'instant de pouvoir mieux lutter contre
les trafics de drogue et bien le fait de
pouvoir par exemple contraventionnelle
ise c'est des lilas et bien je pense en
échangeant avec les acteurs de la
sécurité que c'est de nature à rendre
plus effectives les peine plus que la
lourdeur d'une peine c'est son caractère
inéluctable qui montre son effectivité
ça c'est ce qu'on sait ce que disent les
spécialistes justement de la police et
la justice un dernier mot sur ces
questions puisque vous examinez en ce
moment même le texte sur la justice à
l'assemblée nationale et vous avez
notamment voté la perpétuité à 30 ans
pour les condamner pour les agressent de
sûreté incompressible
une peine de sûreté de trente ans pardon
pour les agresseurs des policiers et des
forces de l'ordre
est ce que il ne faut pas aller plus
loin sur ce sujet et renforcer également
les dispositifs pour les agresseurs
d'élus par exemple moi je crois que là
il y avait un dispositif qui était ciblé
sur nos policiers c'est le débat je
crois qui est le nôtre ce sont eux qui
sont attaqués il ya un autre véhicule
législatif qui concernaient plutôt les
élus sur toutes les dispositions autour
de la protection des élus et nous avons
déjà légiféré dans ce quinquennat sur la
protection des ffi âmes en jeu pour voir
on le voit les agressions et se
multiplient aussi en version on parlait
à l'instant d'effectivité des peines je
pense que c'est plutôt là que se trouve
la réponse il faut évidemment qui est le
respect de l'uniforme
parfois la peur du gendarme d'une
certaine façon bessat ses effectifs
mais derrière ce n'est pas tant la
symbolique de la mesure que encore une
fois
l'effectivité de la peine qui je crois
fera reculer la délinquance dans notre
pays on va parler de la crise sanitaire
et notamment de la vaccination fabrice
alors à partir de la fin du mois tous
français on va pouvoir se faire vacciner
c'est une c'est une nouvelle terre
anticipé avancé alors est ce que le fait
que cette ce calendrier soit modifié ça
démontre aussi que ben il y avait un
petit problème d'approvisionnement sur
les doses en france mais des genres
bonne nouvelle oui évidemment et bonnes
décisions et je crois que si dans
quelques temps on peut tomber le masque
parce que on se sera fait vacciner ça
sera évidemment une bonne nouvelle et je
crois qu'on bicim que ça arrive au
moment où les stocks arrive est ce que
ça veut pas dire comme je l'avais à tj
de priorisation elle était quand même
lié à un manque de l'aude j'allais
revenir exactement là dessus
rappelez-vous les les procès qu'on a
fait à ce gouvernement à cette majorité
pour dire au fond c'est spécifique à la
france vous êtes désorganisé vous n'avez
pas su organiser les centres et settat
et nous nous répondions pas mollo tous
les pays européens vivent la même
situation c'est à dire attendre de
recevoir des stocks et nous nous avons
organisé la politique vaccinale de façon
tout à fait légitime et au contraire ça
a été une force pour la france sur les
premières doses qui arrive et on les
prie horizon sur celles et ceux qui en
avaient le
plus besoin et cette stratégie elle a
fonctionné c'est celle là qui a permis à
l'hôpital de tenir ce celle là qui a
permis effectivement au service de
réanimation de ne pas être débordé mal
vu malgré justement l'intensité cette
fameuse troisième vague
donc c'est exactement la politique qu'il
fallait suivre et maintenant nous avons
des doses qui arrivent massivement il ya
des millions de doses qui vont arriver
des dizaines de millions de doses qui
vont arriver pour le match 1 ils ont ça
va faire en sorte qu'on va pouvoir tenir
notre objectif est pareil pardon mais je
me rappelle de plateaux de télévision on
me disait mais jamais vous tiendrais 10
millions 20 millions 30 millions de
doses mais mais mais juin eh bien nous
sommes exactement dans notre calendrier
en train de le faire on va pouvoir
ouvrir plus largement aux jeunes c'est
une bonne nouvelle évidemment on voit
que c'est conjointement un moment où où
la vie du pays en train de reprendre où
notre économie va pouvoir repartir de
façon d'ailleurs plus vivre aux plus
forte que chez nos voisins européens
parce que nous avons mis en place une
politique du quoi qu'il en coûte
nous sommes en tirant en train d'en
tirer les fruits bien tout ça c'est la
stratégie du gouvernement et je pense
que de temps en temps il faut savoir la
salle mais vous même vous ferai vacciner
c'est peut-être déjà fait bien entendu
non c'est pas encore fait j'attendais
mon tour pouvoir le faire mais
évidemment dès que je pourrais le même
précipité un mot juste sur le pas
salutaire puisque hier députés et
sénateurs se sont mis d'accord sur le
texte de sortie
la crise sanitaire avec notamment la
sortie de l'état d'urgence et le pass
sanitaire qui a été renforcée pour le
coup les députés ont suivi la version
des sénateurs l'encadrement était
nécessaire pour vous de ce pas s'ils ont
eu raison les sénateurs oui je crois que
c'est sage
moi je très favorables aux pass
sanitaires je vous dire j'avais et je
comprends qu'on puisse toujours avoir
des des précautions sur ces sujets là
parce que derrière des sujets de liberté
individuelle de conservation des données
etc
je pense que toutes les garanties ont
été apportées il débat parlementaire a
exactement jouer son rôle c'est à dire
de mettre de la transparence des
garanties de rassurer aussi donc on le
sait sur ce type de dispositif une des
conditions de succès c'est ensuite
justement la transparence et la
confiance d'une certaine façon dont ces
dispositifs
moi je vais vous dire j'ai peu de
prévention je pense que c'est un outil
qui est formidable
justement pour réaccélérer l'ouverture
de notre vie normale et il me semble en
tout cas moi quand j'ai change avec mes
concitoyens dans ma circonscription il
me semble que c'est la priorité pour
tout le monde aujourd'hui donc oui opa
sanitaires et allons vite maintenant un
mot sur une annonce de jean castex était
mercredi lors des questions d'actualité
au sénat sur la loi climat
en tout cas le référendum qui m'a pas
même chose que la loi climat mais la loi
qui introduit la protection de
l'environnement dans la constitution il
a dit qu'elle serait de retour à
l'assemblée nationale
mais il a dû aussi espérer que la
version des députés soient rétablis on
sait députés et sénateurs ne sont pas
d'accord est ce que dire ça ça compromet
pas tout compromis sur ce texte
moi je crois depuis le début que nous
agissons avec sincérité sur cette
question là le président de la
république a dit aux citoyens qui ont
travaillé à cette proposition de
modification je prendrai votre
modification
tel quel dans sa version la plus
ambitieuse et je crois que si on veut
justement modifié avec efficacité notre
constitution il faut adopter cette
version ambitieuse donc je regrette que
effectivement les sénateurs est
amoindrie cette ambition là pour le
changement climatique et or fait une
écriture qui je le dis me semble une
effective et d'une certaine façon un peu
méprisante ce travail des citoyens
puisque ils disent
d'une certaine façon circulez ya rien à
voir on a déjà fait des choses la
constitution et puis on
voie à la charte de l'environnement qui
a déjà été écrite bien moi je crois que
ça n'est pas à la hauteur de la
situation et donc nous garderons cette
version exactement ça je suis dit ce
qu'est un risque avec votre version
notamment une certaine insécurité
juridique mais est sur le manche est
politique je n'ai entendu plusieurs fois
déjà depuis le début du quinquennat on
nous a dit vous modifier le code civil
pour apporter plus de responsabilités
aux entreprises ça va mettre par terre
notre code civil
ceci n'est pas arrivé on m'a dit ça au
moment où j'étais rapportant la droite
sur la loi sur le droit à l'erreur et on
a bien vu que l'état n'a pas été
renversé parce que nous avions inscrit
les principes forts et bien je pense que
c'est la même situation mais je suis
politiquement l'intérêt que c'est notre
ambition sur ce texte là après chalets
les intéresse vous semblez nationale
tout en disant on ne suivra pas la
version du sénat est ce que de facto ce
n'est pas enterré le texte mais parce
que si nous amoindrit sont notre
ambition sur ce texte là et bien nous
renonçons à l'ambition qui était celle
des citoyens et je pense effectivement
pour cette mesure qui a à la fois un
caractère symbolique mais aussi un
caractère effectif
eh bien il faut conserver cette version
donc la manade referenda faudra essayer
de convaincre les sénateurs de changer
d'avis sur ces questions là mais je
pense que nous devons pas rené notre
ambition sur cet axe que l'on compare
faire une absence de référendum une
absence c'est le sénat ont décidé ainsi
malheureusement ce sera le cas on va
parler des régionales et de ce sondage
paru hier sondage ifop dans la région
hôte france qui donne xavier bertrand
gagnant
en tous les cas de figure au premier et
au second tour en triangulaire en
quadrangulaire il ya cinq ministres
quand même qu'ils sont candidats dans
les hauts de france est ce que le fait
que xavier bertrand reste favori des
sondages c'est pas un échec pour vous et
où la majorité vous savez c'est cette
campagne des élections régionales
on en parle souvent ici et je m'en
réjouis mais elle ne fait que commencer
nos consciences bien nos concitoyens oui
mais vous connaissez les conditions très
particulières les changements de date
la crise sanitaire que nous sommes en
train de vivre moi je la proximité de la
présidentielle où vivent peut-être aussi
ça n'explique pas le fait que cette
campagne soit courte en tout cas et je
pense que les gens commencent à
s'intéresser à la campagne et commençant
sincère et campagne des élections
régionales
et bien tant mieux parce que de temps en
temps j'ai l'impression dans les hautes
france par exemple qu'on avait quasiment
un peu oublié qu'il y avait une élection
régionale puisque celles et ceux qui
concourait avait parfois un peu la tête
à autre chose justement que l'élection
régionale je pense à xavier bertrand
vous avez verte on avait l'impression
qu'il y ait même pas des élections
régionales dans sa région il ne nous
parlait que de son destin présidentiel
que de national matin midi et soir
nous avons un excellent candidat
s'appelle laurent petrache skis
qu'effectivement ministres du
gouvernement est extrêmement engagée
dans sa région
eh bien nous allons avoir l'occasion de
faire connaître nos propositions
nos idées et la campagne ne fait que
commencer quand j'ai pris trois vous
savez j'ai toujours été constant les
élections régionales
je vois bien nous sommes entrant dans
cette élection pas toujours facile et
rentrant dans une élection nous on nous
juge parfois comme comme les sortants et
de temps en temps on m'a même dit or il
faudrait mieux même pas joué cette
élection régionale en jambes et d'une
certaine façon mais moi je crois tout le
contraire
quand on a des convictions quand on
porte des idées nous le faisons tous les
jours pour agir pour la transformation
du pays eh bien il faut les porter à
l'élection il faut que la après on va
parler d'autres régions avec fabrice
mais vous avez dit cette semaine dans le
monde xavier bertrand et à une obsession
anti macron vous
voyez cinq ministres contre xavier
bertrand est-ce que c'est pas plutôt
vous qui avez une obsession et xavier
bertrand pardon pardon on n'envoie pas
s'incliner ce contre vous avez bertrand
les ministres qui s'engagent dans cette
élection régionale
à commencer par notre tête de liste lo
rampe et rachel ski eric dupond moretti
qui sera tête de liste dans le pas de
calais ils s'engagent parce qu'ils
aiment cette région parce qu'ils veulent
changer les choses parce que aussi et
singulièrement pour eric dupond moretti
c'est ce qui a conditionné cet
engagement là ils ne veulent pas voir
cette région basculer au front national
et donc ils veulent s'engager pour cette
région qui est la leur sont pas les
parachutages que nous sommes en train de
faire certains de ministre que vous avez
cités sont en fin de liste vous savez
pour pousser pour montrer cet engagement
collectif pour la région parce que nous
le disons une chose très simple
cette élection régionale c'est pour nous
vraiment une élection régionale laurent
pit rachesky dans cette élection
et bien si nous gagnons il sera à la
tête du conseil régional
je trouve ça un peu paradoxal vous me
parlez de xavier bertrand à l'instant de
se présenter à une élection en disant
que dans tous les cas de figure on
quittera la région
il l'a dit façon très claire si je gagne
je ne cèderai pas je quitte la région
parce que j'aurai mon destin national
est super je quitte la vie politique
dont je quitte la région
donc on se présente à une ex en quittant
la région quoi qu'il arrive c'est un peu
paradoxal
eh bien nous nous nous présentons pour
siéger et qui ont eu les souris puisque
c'est si en l'occurrence il sera un
excellent présent deux régions que si
les habitants de l'autre en sus font
confiance alors si on en croit les
sondages c'est pas parti pour mai
évidemment les sondages sont des
sondages et vous avez raison un mois du
scrutin mais il ya quand même un risque
élevé
de victoire du rassemblement national
sur vous vous dites que vous combattez
le rassemblement national et que c'est
votre principal ennemi plus de faire
remarquer qu'il est pas nouveau cette
région en 2015 ce n'est pas nous qui
avons inventé le rassemblement national
temps en temps on semble découvrir tout
ça mais qu'est ce que vous ferez dans
l'entre-deux tours mais nous nous sommes
prêts est ce que vous maintiendrez quoi
qu'il arrive si vous franchissez la
barre d'abord je constate qu'on pose
souvent des questions de deuxième tour
alors même que le premier tour et pas
jouer donc on va jouer pleinement vous
l'avez compris ce premier tour porter
nos idées pour peser le plus possible
dans cette élection
et puis ensuite nous appellerons les uns
et les autres à prendre leurs
responsabilités
quand on veut battre leurs ascendants
nationale alors on doit rassembler
saison devant l'assemblée se trouve un
peu court de temps en temps de dire eh
bien que tout le monde quitte déiste sa
liste et puis ensuite je resterai seul
face aux rassemblements à cela vous avez
désisté la vôtre en paca par exemple
mais au nom d'ailleurs nous allons
résistance au fronton oui ressemble nous
avons choisi de rassemblement il pour
autant monsieur mariani continue à
remonter dans les sondages
qu'est ce qui ne fonctionne pas dans
tout ça d'abord mme soumaré année était
assez haut dans les sondages et ne
faisons pas semblant de découvrir que la
région sud
cette belle région paca peut
effectivement basculé au rassemblement
national
elle n'a pas été loin de le faire en
2015 et le risque il est là et il est
bien là donc soyons lucides sur cette
situation
ensuite moi je considère qu'il faut se
rassembler mais se rassembler dans la
clarté
la politique c'est une question de
conviction c'est une question de clarté
et en l'occurrence c'est ce que nous
avons fait pour la région sud nous avons
dit que nous étions prêts nous étions
prêts à travailler avec des présidents
sortants pas que de droite d'ailleurs
de gauche comme de droite si cela se
faisait dans une condition de clarté
c'était bien de travailler avec la
majorité présidentielle
est ce que on peut mettre un peu les
étiquettes politiques pour gérer
ensemble les transports la formation
professionnelle l'aide aux entreprises
je pense que oui si tenté cela se fait
dans mail
votre candidate qui était sophie cluzel
aujourd'hui elle ne peut plus être
candidate
oui mais après vous savez bien comment
se font les choses il faut constituer ce
que vous avez a perdu sur toute la ligne
là je ne crois vraiment pas je pense que
nous avons fait le choix nous d'être
responsable ce choix n'a pas été
totalement partagée par l'appareil
dlr mais non nous avons fait le choix
d'être responsable et de ne pas tout
conditionné depuis paris de laisser les
acteurs de cette région discuté
travaillé ensemble et trouver des
conditions pour bâtir une liste parce
qu'il s'agit bien de présenter des
listes de constituer un futur exécutif
pour travailler à une liste de
rassemblement et nous avons considéré
que comme la situation était
objectivement perturbé par le national
et par la position nationale des
républicains qui depuis paris on qu'on
dit c'est ont considéré que surtout il
fallait pas travailler avec la majorité
présidentielle
alors nous avons considéré qu'il était
plus sage et renaud muselier a fait ce
choix qu'ils n'aient aucun parlementaire
sûr c'est que vous avez un peu subissent
je n'aime pas nationalisées l'élection
moi je les accepte et je les accepte et
parce que je crois qu'il faut aller avec
sincérité pour une liste d'union dans
l'intérêt de la région
c'est ce qu'attendent 7 les habitants et
je pense que le faire dès le premier
tour
c'est justement la clarté politique un
peu votre idée aussi pour la
présidentielle et l idée qui viendrait
plutôt de les yeux d'ailleurs d'un grand
rassemblement ch'ti l'ump un tel que ça
vous êtes plutôt reposez vous pourquoi
un nom mais un grand mouvement qui
pourrait rassembler le modèle qui
pourrait en outre faire sourire parce
que vous vous cherchez des oppositions
au sein de la majorité
moi les oppositions mais il ya une
logique dans la construction de quelque
chose depuis que je suis déléguée
générale de la république en marche à la
tête du mouvement présidentiel
je plaide sans cesse pour continuer le
dépassement des clivages dans la vie
politique
c'est ce qui a fondé mon engagement dans
la vie politique nationale
non pas montré vous avez du mal avec ce
déplacement effectivement vous preniez
des discussions des accords avec
l'ensemble des présidents sortants sauf
que personne ne vous a suivi à part
peut-être nos ailiers mais aucun nous
est suivi à gauche par exemple vous
voyez qui est capable de faire ce
dépassement la des clivages partisans
particulièrement pour l'élection région
et qui restent enfermés dans ces
majorités régionales dans des logiques
d'appareil bien souvent ce sont des
logiques d'appareil qui consiste à dire
muraille de chine d'une certaine façon
ne travaillez pas avec la majorité
présentielle travail et pas avec la
république en marche parce que sinon
nous perdons toute chance pour 2022
la réalité c'est que ce débat sur les
régionales
il est perturbé par le débat sur les
présidentielles nous avons en tête
un agenda régional nous voulons
effectivement que les régions elles
puissent être des accélératrice de la
croissance on vient de lancer un plan de
relance de 100 milliards d'euros
c'est une opportunité formidable pour
relancer le pays avec les territoires
pour les territoires et puis certains
considèrent que c'est déjà le premier
tour l'élection présidentielle qui se
joue là que surtout il faudrait pas
travailler que la majorité présentielle
parce que ça obérerait les chances
ensuite pour l'élection présentielle
eh bien je crois que c'est se tromper
d'élection et en se trompant élections
on trompe les électeurs et je pense que
c'est dommage pour notre démocratie mais
surtout pour l'intérêt que constitue
cette élection c'est à dire
l'accélération de la relance du pays
et merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin merci fabrice on
regarde la une du progrès merci à binche
la victime à bâle et la gêne avions et
je voulais montrer qu un accident
absolument mais voilà c'est à la une du
progrès aujourd'hui merci messieurs
[Musique]